Oh
but I see the Tea Party movement is
something that's part of a phenomenon
that's going on all over the world now
that there is a general anxiety about
caused by globalization by the influence
of international corporations of
supranational organizations and so on
people feel that they're in a world
where they've lost their grip on who
they are where they belong they don't
know who represents them anymore and so
on and this has led often to defensive
reactions and often hostile reactions
partly against the political elites that
are blamed for this state of affairs
that are blamed for these anxieties and
but also against the alien elements and
the two are linked because in Europe
it's the elites that are blamed for
bringing in the immigrants and for
dismissing everybody who complained
about tensions that come out of large
scale and not very well could manage
dimma gratian that dismiss such such
complaints as racism and so there is a
populists reaction against the elites
which has taken this immigration issue
somehow as a sort of focal point